[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor Andrew Pierce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
Kevin McGuire and uh plenty to talk
about no doubt about that so to the
front pages then let's kick off with the
guardian which suggests the Liz truss's
energy price free though to involve a
cap of two and a half thousand pounds a
year until 2024 could be an attempt to
bring about unity in the conservative
party
150 billion pound scheme to freeze
energy bills for two years reads the
front of the times as they look at the
same story although the mirror welcomes
news of an energy price freeze the paper
points out that mistrust is still
resisting the idea of a windfall tax The
Daily Mail also leads with the prime
minister's prospective energy policy the
headline Liz's energy Revolution here's
the Ivan the headline trust reveals
energy gamble as pound hits a 1985 low
the telegraph hears she'll say britons
should never be put in the position of
paying such expensive Bills ever again
the Ft frames her entry to number 10
against the backdrop of the pound
hitting its lowest level against the
dollar in 37 years and the Metro has the
story of a Canadian student who was
murdered by her boyfriend shortly after
she moved to the UK to be with him and
on a much lighter note the star carries
research suggesting
or a different night rather Jesus might
have played an ancient form of cricket
well reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch
the program so let's go to Andrew Pierce
and Kevin McGuire who join us now and um
you know one big story in town Kevin you
kick off two days in the job and massive
sums of money we're talking about here
no absolutely and she'll make the
announcement for herself tomorrow we'll
actually get the final details uh the
guardian talks about 130 billion package
times in Telegraph 150 billion package
to your freeze although that 2 500 level
would be 25 more than the 2000 uh
ceiling now if you're a typical
household the cap although the
government in the first year would give
you 400 pound towards that second year
we're not so sure I know it's a huge
movement and a guardian for instance
says it's her attempt to unite her party
win over a British public that uh is a
little suspicious about her but it is
yeah the stakes couldn't be higher but
you're right the sums are huge much
bigger than the furlough scheme in
covert although not the total cost of
covered which was about 400 400 billion
but then you know there is uh there's a
huge crisis in their cost of living and
energy bills for people and the dividing
line between the political parties
really are how it pay for it which we
sort of premises questions which uh
kirstana labor were pushing the idea of
a windfall tax to cover at least some of
it Liz truss has got the first windfall
tax but is not going ahead with a wider
windfall tax when the treasury documents
are suggesting there are 170 billion
excess profits for oil and gas producers
because of Putin I mean that's a that's
a lot of blood profits
so what did you call it blood profits
look they're on the back of the invasion
of Ukraine there they're not because a
higher investment or great Innovation or
imagination or risk taking by The
Producers they are because of Putin uh
launched non-provoked invasion of okay
prices yeah yeah I mean I mean they're
also Global profits aren't they not
necessarily all tax
okay Andrew you reflect for us first of
all how she's done so far looking back
to pmqs yesterday too I guess if you
want to and whether this is make or
break for her this announcement tomorrow
well it's not just make or break for her
and the government it's make or break
with the cut for me for literally
millions of families because they simply
would not be able to afford to pay the
energy bills that are coming down the
line when the uh regulator lifts the cap
again and then lifts the cap again next
April we know what Putin is doing he's
closing down that pipeline probably
indefinitely to cause even more pressure
on prices because that's his economic
power we've imposed sanctions on Russia
he's returning the fire uh so I think
she's had a pretty impressive start I
thought she was very uh good in the
comments I thought she got the better of
kirstarma she was helpful once by
Theresa May when Theresa May usually
gets up at primes his questions I'm
certainly when it was with Boris that
was going to be trouble but she asked a
corporate of a question why is it that
um the three women prime ministers have
all been Tory and a great response from
Liz truss yeah and why the last three
labor leaders all been men white men
from North London but look she's had it
she had a pretty confident start in the
comments and this energy package from
the Tory MPS I've talked to pretty
broadly is getting a lot of support
um we're going to get much more detail
tomorrow I don't know if the figures 130
billion or 150 billion but you have to
put this all in context when Gordon
Brown came up with that package to say
package to save the banks back in 2008
it was an outlay of 500 billion which uh
dwarfs both that but both furlough and
the the energy crisis now a lot of that
money was repaid uh we don't know uh if
the energy companies are going to have
to take out loans whether they'll be
guaranteed by the government
um she'll put the detail tomorrow but I
think it's very encouraging I was a
skeptic about a freeze on Energy prices
because I thought rich people get to
benefit much more in a sense than poorer
people but I'm convinced by the argument
it's too too fiddly too time consuming
and actually too expensive to go down
the means testing route so this is the
best approach I suspect and um I think
she'll get certainly a lot of massive
support on the Tory benches we're yet to
see about Labor yes there were two big
questions I guess would any help be
Universal or targeted You could argue
Rishi enacted a hybrid approach 400
pounds for everybody plus plus the
targeted elements like council tax for
example and then how would it be paid
for she ruled out windfall that's the
lead for your paper The Daily Mirror and
Kevin would it be a loan system via the
energy suppliers would it be actually
via borrowing and then later paid back
via General taxation it's likely we
presume to be the latter is it not
uh we do but uh you're going to wait and
see the details because some of it's uh
some of it's briefing some of its
speculation and you want you want you
want to see it but now who uh who pays
in the long run really matters uh and I
think this is why the the windfall tax
isn't just an academic uh issue it is a
real matter a storm up in kyostarma the
labor leader put it in in the terms of
the companies pay big companies getting
excess profits or do working people pay
and literature has made it quite clear
she is against she said a windfall touch
although she is going to continue with
the one unveiled by Rishi sulak when he
was Chancellor and Boris Johnson was the
premise of which he didn't want to go
around that uh down that road again
because she's going to pose as a low tax
um prime minister she is vowing to
reverse the National Insurance uh rise
half of which has been spent actually
already on raising National Insurance
threshold but the rest was supposed to
be going to social care then it spread
to the NHS so to grab a dilemma there
and then she's not going to implement
the Rishi sunak Rising corporation tax
from 19 to 25 that was going to raise 17
billion so she's spending a hell of a
lot of money early and it's a quite a
break from the Cameron era or
uh a bit beyond that which was but
you've got to get spending down you've
got to you've got to reduce debt you
know the national debt now around 100 of
the economy is double what it was in
cash terms uh back in 2010 uh when labor
would be about 40 to be fair but there
we are and um the financial times going
on the concern of the markets
effectively the pound falling again
today and um you know if people are
sitting there thinking well I don't I
can't afford to go on holiday to Europe
anyway this is really about Imports
being expensive being brought into this
country you know whether it's your food
or your your plastic Christmas gifts or
whatever it is which feeds inflation as
well so there's there's big issues about
that and whether interest rates have to
go up to prop up the pound so how do you
see this this fitting into the argument
well this this I mean it the the pound
falling so sharply at one point it was
its lowest level against the dollar
since 1985 it will be inflationary
because we do import so much stuff and
that will mean our Imports will be more
expensive of course perverse on
conversely our exports will be uh
cheaper so it'll be good in that respect
but one of the advantages of the uh
energy freeze it's going to lead to a
very quick sharp fall in inflation which
is going to which will be reassuring for
the markets the stock markets are up uh
retail retail Shares are up uh because
um because it is going to have a big
effect on inflation there were some
pretty apocalyptic predictions that it
could go as high as 18 19 20 even 22 the
salt we've not seen since the 70s really
uh and now there are some suggestions it
could Peak at 12 or 13 or may have
already peaked so that's a huge
Advantage again of the energy freeze but
there's no doubt uh the current see
markets are spooked because of the sheer
scale of the numbers involved and as the
Ft says the sheer scale of the challenge
facing this government and this country
it's huge if we're in an emergency
situation well many people suggest this
is really a story of a strong dollar
um the indication from the US that they
will put up interest rates which is
strengthening the dollar the Yen the
Japanese Yen a 30-year low the Euro low
two Kevin do you want to reflect on that
and also could you bring in the Daily
Telegraph which is another policy
announcement this is the British Bill of
Rights has been scrapped so policies
coming effectively thick and fast so
just uh weave those in if you don't mind
no that's right she's she's trying she's
drawing some lines with Boris Johnson
trying to put a little blue water
between him and her despite the fact she
keeps on on praising him on on the on
the the level of the pound and an
interest rates they could they could go
up pretty rapidly in the UK
unfortunately we've seen uh I think is
it three straight months of increases
but they're going a lot faster in in the
US it's one of the reasons why the pound
is going so low uh but if interest rates
go up well you've got a cost of living
crisis there with people who are
stretched on mortgages and borrowing
whether it's on credit cards or or loans
but the the Bill of Rights which to
replace the landmark here Human Rights
Act of uh 1998 under the labor
government uh the previous Tory
Administration made huge play of that
and how it somehow had to make the
Supreme Court in the UK no longer
um liable to uh decisions on the
European Court of uh human rights which
every European country is signed up to
apart from Russia and Belarus being
being expelled I think it's good she's
dropped it I just hope she doesn't bring
it back but Dominic Robb the Injustice
secretary and was the deputy practical
studies now at the cabinet we've made a
great song and dance about this how this
was hugely hugely necessary this bit
this bill is gone but I'm not sure the
whole concept has gone yet because she
has some pretty reactionary people in
her cabinet yes suggesting there are
better ways to reform human rights law
so we we watch and wait how that one
progresses uh lots of Hospital can we
cross the pond as well the uh the news
that broke that allegations that Donald
Trump had foreign nuclear secrets in his
possession after he left office uh back
with that in just a moment
[Music]
thank you
welcome mate you're watching the Press
preview with me once again Andrew Pierce
and Kevin McGuire welcome back to both
of you
um let's go to the front page of the
Guardian story that broke um I guess
last night this is what was found at
Trump's Mar-A-Lago estate we called an
estate it's also a club accessible by
people who can get in
um from afar so tell us why this is so
significant and Andrew why it might be
even more serious for for president
Trump
well it's extraordinary we we know when
he when he left the White House he just
helped himself to a lot of incredible a
large number of classified documents but
it now transpires some of them included
the um uh the defense and intelligence
preparations including nuclear
facilities for an as an undisclosed
foreign government so the so the now
Mar-A-Lago has been become a magnet for
foreign spies who want to see if they
can get their hands on any of this
material I mean what was Trump thinking
of I mean not only did he try and um
overturn the election result he's he's
taken away really important classified
documents from the White House they know
this is now beginning to hurt the
Republicans in the polls because oh
Dopey Joe Biden looked like he was going
to go down to a really bad midterm
defeat in November in these elections
but actually uh his his ratings are
recovering and the Dem Republicans are
plummeting and I think it's the Trump
effect
well this is um all via the Washington
Post who suggested there were papers
marked sap special Access program which
were offered about active U.S
intelligence operations potentially more
disturbing paper stamped HCS human
control system involving human
intelligence gathered from agents in
enemy countries whose lives would be in
danger if their identities were
compromised suggestion now that this is
more likely to lead to criminal charges
against Mr Trump but we um we watch and
wait which leaves you with the Royals
Kevin I've done this all wrong I know
um so that the picture that's been
released
well he could give it a quick go and
then you can take over should we do that
anyway so we've got the um the pictures
of the Two Princes and princess on the
way to school and the news that the
queen has missed this important privy
council meeting which would have led to
mistrust taking an oath as first Lord of
the treasury at that at that meeting
Kevin yeah I suppose the kids go to
school at a very exclusive private
school less 60 Grand a year just shows
you they don't really live lives that's
how most of the people do and probably
pay very little attention to the lives
of other people but the queen at 96
canceling what would have been an online
meeting you've got to say
um really will fuel fears about her
health after she stayed in Balmoral
didn't go down to Buckingham Palace to
see Johnson out and uh and Trust in and
she looks a lot smaller and older I mean
she she is 96 but you can you can see
she's alien and and fading and it will
be the end of an era I'm a republican
but I I wish her well as an individual
and as a human
um but you can you can see it's the late
Autumn of her life now
um she can't do it at all she she cannot
do the job that she's supposed to do and
I think we need to address in future
apologies for rushing you um we've run
out of time but uh you know still with
us sparkling smile I have to say in
those pictures released uh yesterday
Kevin Andrew thank you